I'm in my hotel room in Sydney Australia
where I'm staying for a conference
before I start my lecture tour going
around various cities in Australia and
I've just read the paper which I think
so exciting that I thought I should tell
you about it before we make a bigger
video when the results of the paper are
fully known
the papers in the journal science and
it's about looking for new super-heavy
elements though the current state of
play is that there is some evidence for
all the elements up to an including 118
now the evidence for the last few is not
equally good so elements 114 now and 116
are about to be named and 113 115 and
we're still waiting for confirmation but
essentially the whole of the periodic
table is more or less known in some of
my videos the ones about 118 I said that
I thought there was no chance of ever
seeing elements beyond 118 and the point
about this paper is that it says that
scientists are looking for and believed
they might find element 120 now what
they're saying is they may be able to
start finding elements in this part in
the next row as you will have seen
people have predicted how the periodic
table might appear lower down here right
up to element 172 what has happened is
that chemists and physicists have
predicted that if you make heavier
elements that there may be a few
arrangements of neutrons and protons
which are much more stable than these
very unstable elements over here and
they call this the island of stability
it's because if you plot out as they
have done in picture here the numbers of
protons and neutrons you can get areas
which appear like an island where the
elements are stable and then there are
other combinations which are not stable
what people are doing is trying to make
these elements in the same way that
they've done before where you take a
heavy element with a
heavy nucleus and bombard it with
lighter elements and you choose the
combination so that the mass of the
light element and the heavy element
makes the one you're trying to
synthesize so in this case the
experiments described in this paper are
taking titanium which has atomic number
22 and californium which has atomic
number 98 and if you add 22 plus 98 you
get a hundred and twenty so the
experiment consists of accelerating
nuclei of titanium atoms at enormous ly
high speed a fraction of the speed of
light and letting it bang in to the
sample of californium and most of the
time the titanium just bounces off in
some random direction but what they hope
is that every so often and it hasn't
happened yet but every so often one of
these titanium nuclei will hit the
californium in such a way that it will
go inside and you can see it's quite a
hard process but it can go inside so you
then have the combined nucleus with mass
120 + this nucleus then shoots out of
the back of the target and towards your
detector but there's all sorts of
fragments of atoms being knocked out to
the back of the target so the key is
that you have to have a really good
separator based on magnetic fields so if
you make a nucleus of 120 element 120 it
will whiz out and hit the detector
without most of the other junk once it
gets to the detector as with previous
super-heavy elements it will all being
will stick into the detector and then
once it's there
it will begin decaying and out of the
nucleus will come smaller fragments what
the point of the experiment is that
people can predict fairly accurately
what would come out of a nucleus of
element 120 if it was made so if they
see those bits they can recognize
they've made element 120 so far they
haven't seen anything at all the
experiments that were described in this
paper are being done in the Institute in
dumb start where we visited a few months
ago to look at elements like Boreum and
hassium where they were synthesized the
reason why the experiments get difficult
is each time the nucleus you're trying
to make gets heavier the chances of your
accelerated atom and the target fusing
together get smaller and smaller and
smaller so the experiment gets more and
more difficult to do you have to
understand the titanium atoms are coming
a billions every second and they're
running the experiments for weeks if not
months in the hope of just seeing one
atom coming out so the probability is
pretty small the reason why they're
trying to make 120 rather than 119 which
would be the next atom in the periodic
table after 118 so you've got one
hundred and eighteen hundred nineteen
hundred and twenty but already it
becomes clear it's become clear that
elements that have an even number of
protons that's one hundred fourteen
hundred 1618 are more stable than the
ones with odd numbers so it makes sense
to look for 120 before trying to find
119 I don't know but it is connected
with the fact that the neutrons and the
protons in the nucleus
form shells rather in the same way that
you get shells of electrons in the atoms
though exactly how they form the shells
I don't know the hope is that perhaps
some of these super-heavy elements
really may be much more stable than
anything they've seen before
after all the targets they're using
californium wasn't known when I was born
and now you can make enough californium
to have a metal target made out of it so
I doubt whether you will be able to have
lumps of element 120 or one of the high
ones but you might be able to and
whatever happens you'll have a much
better understanding of what it is that
makes atoms form and what are the
limitations what are the rules that hold
them together so this is not the sort of
experiment that will necessarily give
you new iPhone tomorrow but on the other
hand it will give us a lot of scientific
understanding so it's well worth doing
well I think that will be quite fun